Pull.
Turn.
Nice.
That was awesome.
Good job!
I'm gonna take her off the groomed terrain for the first time...
...into some powder, into some bumps.
Peter was so helpful.
You know, I think that when it comes to learning something new,...
...it's all about your mindset,...
...and it's all about staying positive and if I fall, I fall.
I'm gonna get up and I'm gonna keep going, that's how you learn.
I have been in the snow involuntarily a couple of times.
I'm still coming out dry.
I've got an Omni-Heat Base Layer on...
...and just my shell, and it's been plenty for me.
I've stayed warm, I've stayed dry, and I've been out all day.
The Olympic downhill run was awesome, I didn't even realize...
...that we were on a black diamond until we were near the bottom.